hace más de un año uno de los peores
temores del Consejo de Seguridad de la
ONU se hizo realidad
solo puedo declarar con pesar que
nuestras señales aquí sobre la necesidad
de poner fin a las provocaciones contra
las repúblicas populares de Don iess y
lugares que no fueron escuchadas
en febrero de 2022 cuando Rusia invadió
Ucrania ostentaba la presidencia
rotatoria del Consejo de Seguridad de la
ONU ahora vuelve a ser su turno a pesar
del malestar por la guerra en Ucrania
sobre el papel el consejo de seguridad
de la ONU es el organismo encargado de
mantener la paz y la seguridad en el
mundo y que lo presida Rusia ha
suscitado críticas y la condena directa
de Ucrania
No hay forma de terror que Rusia no haya
cometido ya Y no habrá ninguna razón que
detenga la reforma de las instituciones
globales en particular el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU la reforma Que
obviamente está trazada evita que un
estado terrorista y cualquier otro
estado que quiera ser terrorista
destruya
pero no es nada fácil sacar a Rusia de
la ecuación además de tener derecho a la
presidencia rotativa entre los 15 países
miembro Rusia es uno de los cinco
miembros permanentes del organismo junto
a China Estados Unidos Francia y Reino
Unido por lo que también tiene derecho
abeto lo que quiere decir que puede
bloquear cualquier decisión importante
sin importar con el número de votos que
cuente Pero cuál es el impacto Real de
la presidencia de Rusia en el consejo es
más bien simbólico Rusia ya ha dicho que
va a hacer uso pleno de sus derechos y
que quiere poner sobre la mesa varios
debates sobre temas como el nuevo orden
mundial o el control de armas a pesar de
condenas internacionales como la de la
cpi contra el presidente Vladimir Putin
por supuesto tráfico de menores
ucranianos la realidad es que no hay
ninguna vía legal para destituir a un
miembro permanente del Consejo por lo
tanto Rusia va a seguir teniendo
supuesto reservado allí